well love wasn't in the air
unfortunately for everybody and today
is single awareness day to celebrate you
may want to do something fun with
friends
maybe even by yourself we have a home in
live at duelingx's with one idea
all right bianca good morning can't wait
to see it
hey good morning alex so yeah if you are
waking up happily single and you want to
celebrate your singleness or maybe
you're waking up and you didn't get any
flowers or chocolates yesterday so
you're angry and you want to let off
some steamed and you want to ask your ex
this is the place to go
so i'm here joined by david patterson uh
peterson excuse me
uh with here at dueling acts as a
general manager so i know you all were
busy yesterday but i bet you're probably
gonna be even busier today because it's
a lounge
throwing axes good music good food
absolutely well i mean
yesterday we were busy and we're looking
to be busy today to help some people
grind some axes
and also like you said have a lounge
some soft seating a bar area
and also some coaches who can help
people stick it yes okay now
you guys i didn't stick it last time it
fell off it hit but it didn't it didn't
stick
we're gonna stick it this time some
coaching going all right let's trade
let's trade
all right all right just like we
practice it okay
right hand right over that okay you're
gonna take a step
right above your head you're going to
take a step there and release
i am the best coach in the world
yes we made it it was almost a bullseye
it's almost right there you guys i think
i've been practicing all
this time for about a good 15 minutes oh
so yes
come here be like me you know let off
some steam have some fun with friends
and of course again like you all said
the
capacity is increasing so six to a table
now
increasing that uh capacity absolutely
so stick to a table with some friends
and if you have more than that we'll put
you in the lane right next to each other
so you can have some fun
all right you guys it took some practice
but we made it so
of course we're gonna have all this
information we've tweeted it out
gonna be on our website we're gonna send
it back to you guys in the studio uh
bianca that was scary good no one's
gonna ever mess with you ever again if
they thought about it
good job exactly great money shot
all right thanks bianca